hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today like I said it's dip stream recap
date like always and there was four
million watch the news today it's pretty
slow news day here since we just started
a new season what there's a few bits of
information to talk about so as always
like the video if you do enjoy
subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being balanced changes updates weekly
dead streams and new event details all
of all that type of stuff and with that
let's get started so first up a couple
of you guys told me about this during my
livestream but apparently last week
everyone got the old season 1 ornaments
for the old characters that being the
original 12 character cast so if you
happen to see a new ornament in your
inventory for the character you play
that's why I'm unsure if you got the
ornaments for the DLC characters but I
do know that you do get the ornaments
for the original cast of characters next
up the devs talked about a few things
that they're working on it currently one
of them being a matchmaking tool that
they're playing with and it basically
sum it up it tries as hard as it
possibly can to match people with the
exact same skill and reputation level to
make matches more balanced there is
already a matchmaking tool like this in
the game but they're trying and working
hard to make it better this is still in
development so there isn't any really
release date for this just yet and on
top of that they're working on two fixed
revenge because not as great as it was
season 1 revenge if you guys don't
remember was completely unbalanced and
basically really good where people would
just block and then get revenge just to
win that teamfight and now the nerfs to
it I've dumbed it down off maybe a
little bit too far so they're testing
out some new ideas that they have for it
once again no release day on either of
these two things since they don't want
to release this too early without
testing it but I'll keep you guys up to
date on anything that changes going off
the weekly orders that we've been seeing
for the event the Knights 1 across all
platforms the Bell vol Medusa order so
enjoyed the steel and crates of course
enjoy the stealing crates for everybody
except but of course the Knights got
more because they got first place the
Musashi the crane order now is up and
currently ongoing at where you have to
be the first faction to play the most
matches with samurai heroes and then
next week we're gonna get the last order
which is Heydrich the Warthog where it's
basically the same premise as the other
two except mellow Viking heroes also
just a reminder that the new champion
status is going to be going on sale
until then of the events I highly
recommend you buy that before the sale
ends also the new sword in the stone
emote is now currently in the game which
I'm playing on screen this will be
available from now until next Thursday
then it's gone
so definitely invite this emo before it
disappears forever and on top of that
there's going to be a bundle that comes
with the sword in the stone emote the
Illumina time loop and I believe the
masks as well this is starting today May
24th and then ends June 4th so you have
a little bit of time even after the
event to get this bundle for the
character that you want and if you're
unfamiliar how this stuff works
basically let's just set an example of
the base price being 30000 to get
everything up in the event but let's say
I play gladiator and the thing is 30k
but I already have the mask outfit so
the price is gonna go down more because
the game doesn't want you to pay double
for something you already have so the
more items you have for that character
the less the bundle is going to cost
also and lastly to end the video I
forgot to mention this last week but if
you happen to write or draw and you feel
like you're very good at it you can make
fanfiction or fan art about 4 on or
using the hashtag FF hero creations
you can check reddit or the actual four
on our website for more details I
believe you have to like email them or
something like that I wasn't really too
into this portion because I am
personally not a writer or draw but if
one of you guys are and you're
interested you can definitely go on here
and maybe win some cool prizes they
never really stated what you could win
but it's cool that they're having this
and showing that off for the fanfic
people and the fan artists but that guy
is gonna be the end of the video today
hope you guys did enjoy like I said a
pretty slow news day nothing too much
but there was a few bits of info that
I'd like to share with you all like the
video if you did enjoy it really just
help me out subscribe for new I cover
the leaks the informational side of
foreigner like I've stated previously
the balance updates the patch notes the
new event details new updates all that
type of stuff I like the cover here on
the channel my two most recent videos
are gonna be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out one of them is
all the details that you need to know on
this new event just in case you're
unaware of what's going on and you're a
little bit not caught up to date I'll
keep you all covered with that video and
then the other one has to deal with the
loot that came up with this limited time
event if you want to get that all the
fastest and without having to pay steel
for all the bundles and stuff definitely
go check out that video for a step to
step guide and how to do it and with
that guys hope every rest your day and
peace out thank you for watching the
video